LEGISLATURE VOTED NOT TO PURSUE
A NEW BAN ON ASSAULT RIFLES.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
REPUBLICANS ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ARE
LAUNCHING A NEW OFFENSE OF
TONIGHT REGARDING ALLEGED
SURVEILLANCE ABUSE DURING THE
2016 ELECTION THAT GOES BEYOND
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS THE
LATEST.
>> WITH THE CURRENT AND FORMER
OFFICIALS, REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN
OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
THE TRUMP DOSSIER INVESTIGATION.
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES POSED A
STRING OF DOSSIER RELATED
QUESTIONS, COVERING WHEN
OFFICIALS LEARNED THE DNC AND
CLINTON CAMPAIGN PAID FOR THE
RESEARCH.
AS WELL AS HOW THEY DOSSIER WAS
USED TO SECURE ONE OR MORE
SURVEILLANCE WARRANTS.
FOX NEWS LEARNED THE
QUESTIONNAIRE, INCLUDING A
THREAT TO SUBPOENA, WENT TO
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY,
FORMER DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JAMES CLAPPER AND
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN.
THE REPUBLICAN STAFF MEMO
RELEASED THIS MONTH SAID FBI AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT KNEW ABOUT
THE DOSSIERS DEMOCRATIC ROOTS.
IT ASKED THE COURT TO COLLECT
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AIDE CARTER
PAGE'S COMMUNICATIONS.
A YEAR LATER, JOHN BRENNAN
TESTIFIED HE DIDN'T KNOW THE
WHOLE DOSSIER STORY.
>> DIRECTOR BRENNAN, DO YOU KNOW
WHO COMMISSIONED THE STEELE
DOSSIER?
>> I DON'T.
>> DO YOU KNOW IF THE BUREAU
RELIED ON THE STEELE DOSSIER IS
PART OF ANY COURT FILINGS,
APPLICATIONS, POSITIONS?
>> I HAVE NO AWARENESS.
>> LONDON LAWYER ENTERED A
WASHINGTON, D.C., FEDERAL COURT
AND PLED GUILTY TO LYING.
HE LIED ABOUT HIS COMMUNICATIONS
TWO MONTHS BEFORE THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
ALONG WITH HIS BUSINESS PARTNER
AND FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
CHAIRMAN PAUL MANAFORT, GATES
WAS INDICTED.
WHITE HOUSE SPOKESMAN SAID THE
GUILTY PLEA IS MANY STEPS
REMOVED FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNCILS COLLUSION MANDATE.
>> THIS HAS TO DO WITH AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING ONE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WAS ALREADY BEEN
INDICTED.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ACTIONS RELATED TO THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> THE GUILTY PLEA PUTS PRESSURE